Languages change over time,
but you already know that much.
If you've gone through my
intro to language history,
you've seen how an individual word changes
as it passes from a protal language
interrelated daughter languages where
it transforms into distinct words called
cognates.
The differences between cognates show
up most noticeably in the way the words
sound.
We were able to use these differences
to spot sound correspondences that mark
cognates in their related languages,
but also to recognize the sound changes
that separate the daughter languages
from their common parent.
In this series,
we'll take a closer look at the types of
sound change that shaped the history of
languages and language.
Families all around the world foreign
and familiar like historical linguistics,
often split sound change into two halves,
regular changes versus irregular changes.
A regular sound change takes place
systematically and in every instance of an
environment. For example, if a
language undergoes a sound change,
where are becomes pronounced?
Ooh, every er will change too.
If in that same language turns
into mm between a vowel and a B,
then every mm found after a val and
before a B will undergo that sound change.
Early in the 20th century,
the regularity hypothesis proposed that
all sound change naturally works this
way. Irregular sound changes
are quirky in nature.
They're actually known as sporadic
sound changes because the sound change
doesn't occur routinely
in a given environment.
Let's take an example from English.
Some older dialects of English
pronounced the word for a male Fox,
Fox and the word for a female of the
species fixing in other dialects.
The two words started with a
VA thanks to dialect mixing.
Modern English speakers inherited a bit
of both leaving us with Fox and vixen.
The change from dramatic foe to
modern English in vixen is sporadic.
Since it doesn't match up with
any regular across the board.
Sound change in modern English.
To understand sporadic sound change,
we'd really need to look into the
features of local dialects and regional
language patterns.
That's at least the case in the Fox
vixen example I gave where the two words
descend from two different dialects.
We aren't going to attempt to uncover
the background behind that kind of sound
change here.
Instead,
the topic of regular sound change will
be the order of the day. This series,
we'll look at the various types of regular
pronunciation change that are common
to languages around the world,
be they foreign languages like Japanese
and Arabic or native ones like English.
We'll also see how these changes very
often make combinations of sounds easier
to pronounce.
In other words,
one of the key motivations for
speakers to change a sound is ease of
articulation.
For any viewers who aren't yet familiar
with language change and reconstructed
languages, I'll leave you with
another link to that series. Also,
since we're going to focus on
the change part of sound change,
you'll need a basic understanding of
sounds. If that's where you're at.
Checkout this video series
first in the next video.
It's onto the various processes of
stem change starting with assimilation.
Thanks for watching.
Okay.